and guys I'm actually reading the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book right now
never read it I love it man I can't wait
to see Silver Surfer I can't wait to see
Professor Xavier just like how they are
in the comics and they're gonna be in
here really really faithful one told ya
later death who rescues Thanos it's
gonna be so accurate to the comics let's
spoil the movie for Sorry Sorry
all right when I was reading him like
man I'm really getting the download area
is gonna cater and halfway to see all
this brought to the good life on a
reject nation less than a month from now
ah we will be watching Avengers infinity
war and while there are several TV spots
out now we're gonna watch two today with
you guys let's start off with spider-man
is Avenger or some other better TV spot
title but I'm sure that's what this this
is about big revelation here guys huge
revelation here spider-man's and
Avengers tony'll actually let him in
what we did not see that coming he's
just a kid though you would think the
title might have known negated that I'll
believe it I'll buy it but apparently he
is prove it okay this is some hold this
[Laughter]
[Music]
iron spider I actually love that this
will be the last time we watch TV spot
kind of which I did to see them over to
the theaters I mean we brought this on
ourselves and homecoming all Peter wants
for like most of the movie is to become
an Avenger you know there's a big drive
that has this whole arms look you know I
don't really need to come in adventure
yet I just want experience in New York
it's very nice that's how this works you
know you give up the thing you thought
you wanted and then you know life
rewards you with the thing you know
every good narrative wraps up and the
reason I love it is because there's all
that build-up in part one right here it
just doesn't like it's nothing all right
you're extraneous circumstances we don't
have time for anything ceremonious
you're just let's go we get to see Hulk
yelling some people have been missing
from these infinity war trailers we got
to see it why that's confirmed gone TV
spot he won't stop until he destroys
half the universe everything
everything you love it will all be gone
[Applause]
tweaking storage channels by those
you don't want to join
but we will
[Applause]
are you--oh part two killing this town
black widows gonna kill them back widows
gonna knock it out the park
I think these trailers are so smart
because the big tease with the trailers
are who's gonna die yeah which vendors
are we gonna say goodbye everyone you
love and they used to do the shot of
vision in human form with Scarlet Witch
even they may be a different shot two of
dr. strange where he's closing his eyes
and the glass is peeking in on his cheek
as if he's like preparing to die in this
very moment he's accepted it he only
gets one movie and then he dies how
unfair oh you even get a little if you
slow it down you get a little get a
little shot of a koi a fighting here
with someone and you meant some black
widow action I guess the big line is you
know Thor saying we need to stop that
owes I'm assuming this is after he
watches Loki die maybe
Loki's barely in the trailer in any of
these trailers I'm assuming Loki dies in
that scene and then he comes back to the
post-credits scene yeah I never realized
how Loki does yeah Loki can never die
Loki can never die so we learn from the
MCU films you guys gettin subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell cuz it does something and check us
out on patreon it's fun over there you
didn't you'll have fun I'll have fun we
all have fun we're all dudes Hey